this movie borrowed something from me
something borrowed stars Jennifer
Goodwin Kate Hudson John Krasinski and
some guy named Colin basically Jennifer
Goodwin has always liked this guy and
now he's marrying her best friend played
by Kate Hudson she's kind of caught in
this thing where she like really wants
to be with him but she doesn't know if
he wants her and it's her best friend so
she can't just be like hey you know what
I kind of am in love with your fiancee
and I just you know it creates a big
romantic comedy wonderful thing where
some guy would probably pitch this to a
studio and they go oh yeah we get a
whole bunch of girls to come into our
theater and watch a movie that
completely disrespects them it doesn't
have any respect for female intelligence
whatsoever and they'll just lap it up
and love it and think it's the greatest
thing ever and not even realize how
stupid it is Something Borrowed isn't an
awful movie every single character in
this film except one are idiots they are
the stupidest dumbest people that have
absolutely no idea how to live their
life or make decisions or choose the
right path they're just so stupid the
only character in this film that has any
smarts to him whatsoever that I actually
enjoyed is John Krasinski he was very
funny in this movie and he consistently
says things - the main girl and asks her
questions that I was thinking basically
he just keeps saying you know you're
stupid you need to go out there and get
what you want or figure out what you
want or make it a season or something
every character in this movie is so
maddeningly
stupid they make decisions and you just
sit there going why are you doing that
this brings me to Kate Hudson she is in
the same movies over and over she's just
in an endless line of horrible romantic
comedies and she's just some bubbly
chicken every movie who seem is drunken
every single scene honestly if you start
off everything this movie thinking Kate
Hudson's drunk right now
it works you know just like you know I'm
just gonna do this I'm Kate Hudson I
mean seriously I just I don't get it I
don't get she's a terrible actress John
Krasinski is the only entertainer thing
this movie he's funny his character
actually seems smart and makes sense the
other problem is this film is a romantic
comedy and it makes the fatal flaw of in
my opinion the characters ending up with
the wrong person at the end I don't
think that the characters are with the
right person at the end of this film
they decide to spend their lives with it
just doesn't make sense it's for the
worst films of the year so far maybe the
worst honestly I'm not positive I really
hated this film disrespects the
intelligence of women and thinks we're
all stupid and it is just an endless
soap opera of cliches that just pile up
on one another and youth like could it
be it couldn't be any worse no more
random things happen that would never
happen in real life stupid characters
horrible writing made-for-tv movie
direction I'm gonna give this film 1 out
of 4 stars it's a bad point please don't
take this movie